[Musique]
la tragédie de la mosquée de québec nous
a ouvert les yeux sur notre
méconnaissance souvent profondes la
réalité des musulmans par exemple
premier y at-il de musulmans au canada
ou au québec
dans un sondage de radio canada les
répondants ont estimé en moyenne à 8 %
de l'ensemble de la population
la réalité division par 2 soustrayant
encore un peu plus de 3% et ce pour
l'ensemble du canada comme programme du
québec frédéric castel on parle de
musulmans on parle de religion
jusqu'à quel point est ce que les
musulmans pratiquent leur religion
ben dans les chiffres que l'on tombe
dispose seront pas très nombreux on sait
que environ 15% des musulmans du québec
fréquente la mosquée à chaque semaine
alors que 60% par ailleurs n'y vont
jamais à l'intérieur d'une année et
c'est entre les deux on a les gens qui
fréquentent plus la mosquée il entend
des fêtes les musulmans qui vivent au
canada au québec viennent de beaucoup de
pays
en gros aux anglais je suis leur origine
alors dans le cas du québec compte tenu
de son aspect francophone on n'a plus
une migration qui viennent les pays
francophones en l'occurrence les pays
arabes ou berbères disons cela comme ça
l'afrique subsaharienne il vient prendre
une variété de gens qui viennent
d'autres régions du monde asie du sud il
rentre dans le code canada anglais bien
c'est les gens qui viennent d'asie du
sud est des pays comme louette qui
l'emportent à l'instant selon de deux
univers que cela différents trésors ou
berbères au québec était un dock cette
année au canada anglais de quelle façon
est-ce qu'on peut comparer le taux de
francisation des maghrébins et des
musulmans donc au québec avec les autres
communautés
et quand on est rendu à plus de 80% de
connaissance du français
c'est hors norme généralement les
populations d'arrivée récente on a
souvent des taux de connaissance du
français de 50 à 60%
alors c'est bien au delà des normes pour
les populations arrivé récemment
donc on a affaire à des communautés qui
sont diplômés éduquer est ce que le
portrait est pas mal le même canada un
peu partout où elles font vraiment le
même à l'ensemble du canada hausse modo
entre 30 et 50 % des femmes ont un
diplôme universitaire et entre 40 et 60
% des hommes ont-elles grade
j'en perds souvent de ghettoïsation des
communautés pas seulement chez les
musulmans mais est ce qu'il ya un risque
de ghettoïsation des populations
musulmanes chez nous la recherche nous a
montré que ça n'est pas le cas au canada
les populations musulmanes d'ailleurs
sont variés du point de vue
les heurts entre groupes ethniques n'ont
pas les mêmes quartiers se dispersent à
travers la ville ça c'est archi
documentée et l'autre par une attitude
venant des gens qui connaissent l'europe
ils ne veulent pas c'est une décision
collective visuels de poids se
ghettoïser donc on va tout faire pour
qu'une miette aux opérateurs que sa
masse qu'on a vu en europe par les
xénophobes et on pense mosquée mosquée
dans son quartier il ya eu des
résistances dans certaines villes avoir
des mosquées s'implanter d'abord combien
de mosquées au québec
je dirais qu'il soit 40 lieux de culte
juifs romandie lieux de culte parce que
mosquée on s'imagine un gros bâtiments
communaux vise 80 qui remplit 500 à 2000
personnes souvent les mots ce qu'ils se
sont dit du recul qui peuvent compter 50
à 200 personnes
qu'est ce que c'est l'islamisme c'est un
rapport avec la religion
c'est ce qu'ils croient que la religion
ne doit pas être écarté du champ
politique
car sans cela c'est une logique anti
laïques son poil est définie est ce
qu'un lien entre le port du voile puis
l'islamisme il ya eu plutôt un phénomène
que je qualifierais n'ont pas de montée
de l'islamisme est trop réducteur mais
plutôt à un renouveau le dame qui était
en même temps une dimension je dirais
culturelle identitaire
ces femmes qui aujourd'hui porte le
voile au québec sont davantage dans
cette façon de penser la religion que
oui on peut vivre comme citoyens
citoyennes dans la société soit en un
serment adhéré au mouvement de partis
politiques au nom de cancale et de
surtout instiller l'idée que l'islam est
soluble dans la démocratie la modernité
on assiste à une montée du populisme en
europe aux etats unis en partie au
canada est ce que les musulmans de
doivent se sentir menacé
malheureusement l'échelle internationale
on constate une vision négative des
populations vis-à-vis les mineurs
religieuses notamment musulmanes et on a
monté une croissance des actes et
les avis probablement des mosquées ou
même des synagogues au canada donc c'est
pas croissance at il noté jusqu'où est
ce qu'on peut parler d' islamophobie
chez nous alors dans le camp près du
texte de deux modèles de souris jusqu'à
nos phobies lourde qui est le trait
théorisé très bien a commenté avec
beaucoup d'information alternative
pourrait dire ça comme ça avec des idées
complotistes dynamisation l'occident est
institué avec une parole purement qui
mène à la rue une autre forme plus
légère du thème aux phobies commune de
jacques tchèque le mandat population qui
s'interroge s'inquiète vis-à-vis des
minorités qu'ils ne connaissent pas que
nos frais campo alors la question de
fond c'est est ce que ces minorités
religieuses continuent leur foi
pourront-ils s'intégrer la société
canadienne par le biais du travail par
le biais du voisinage donc question
humaine mais qui peut se baser sur la
méconnaissance de ces coupes
est ce que il ne risquera pas ces
musulmans justement pour ceux qui en ont
peur de vouloir imposer la charia au
canada l'imposition d'un chariot fait
partie d'un agenda islamiste à travers
le monde donc c'est un peu normal qu'ils
connaissent des hausses des taux se
demande si ça vaut parise c'est un pur
on est dans les stérilités et dans les
faits quand on fait du terrain
moindrement au canada on se rend compte
que c'est un non-sujet le respect de la
charia
la majorité des milieux musulmans la
crainte est légitime mais il dans
l'équipe
c'est pas un sujet de discussion à
l'interné comme tu es musulman parce
qu'on peut faire une critique de l'islam
ça est restée à ma femme absolument
on peut critiquer l'islam comme toute
autre religion
lorsque l'on met en lumière des pointes
doctrine qui dérange
nous sommes un confit tuer luke semble
gêner la vie en société ou qui semble
contradictoire et toutes les religions
le fond à l'inter de toute façon ce juge
de pompey ne pas tomber dans
l'irrationalité est-ce que l'attentât de
la mosquée avec change des choses
oui mais parce qu'on ne sait jamais ce
qui va arriver en quelques mots mais à
ce moment c'est on dirait que c'est un
parent bien dramatique ça risque de
donner de bonté dans ce qu'on observe
c'est passe à québec la population
québécoise à monter massivement une
seule vérité même de l'émotion ça crée
une connexion inattendue entre coptes et
musulmans de la ville de québec et son
mari la classe politique je crois qu'à
une connexion qui avait peut-être
peut-être même pas avancé et de façon
plus globale la prise de conscience à
lescure en amont prévu contre je crois
pas qu'on puisse refuser
bravo paul